a
[Música]
ah
desde el inicio de la pandemia corea del
sur ha empleado aplicaciones telefónicas
para controlar a los que entran en su
territorio su protocolo que le ha
permitido mantener abiertas las
fronteras en todo momento y que sigue
vigente obliga a todo aquel que llega al
país a someterse a una prueba pcr tras
aterrizar y a descargarse una aplicación
desarrollada por el ministerio del
interior para cumplir con la cuarentena
obligatoria de 14 días esta app sirve
para reportar dos veces al día a las
autoridades si el viajero tiene unos
síntomas y ante todo controla mediante
señal gps si la persona sale o no del
recinto donde debe cumplir esa 40 en
obligatoria debido a esto muchas
personas han protestado por lo intrusivo
del sistema cuando por ejemplo las
autoridades les han llamado porque han
pasado más de dos horas sin tocar sus
teléfonos y sospechan que han podido
vulnerar sus cuarentenas dejando los
dispositivos en casa en todo caso una
mayoría de surcoreanos apoyan la
efectividad de este sistema sobre todo
teniendo en cuenta que el país está
registrando estos días apenas decenas de
nuevos casos diarios y sigue siendo uno
de los menos afectados en el mundo por
lakovic 19
[Música]
francia va a estrenar una nueva
aplicación de rastreo para coronavirus
esto ante el rotundo fracaso de esto con
la aplicación presentada en el mes de
mayo y que era clave para la salida del
confinamiento pero cinco meses más tarde
tan solo 3.5 por ciento de los franceses
la descargaron cuando se necesita que
sea al menos el 10 por ciento de la
población que la tenga en sus teléfonos
celulares para que ésta funcione y se
puedan rastrear los contactos de las
personas que han dado positivo por kobe
de 19
además de estos los franceses han sido
muy reacios en utilizarla porque temen
que se podrá utilizar su información
personal y que además ésta pueda ser
filtrada por otra parte y en vista de
esto pues el gobierno ha tomado la
decisión de sacar una nueva aplicación
que será presentada este 22 de octubre
una aplicación mucho más interactiva en
la que puedan consultarse cifras sobre
la epidemia y que como su antecesora
pues también funcionará con tecnología
bluetooth® para proteger según explica
el gobierno la vida privada de las
personas
[Música]
en colombia desde el inicio de la
pandemia el presidente iván duque apostó
por la creación de una corona up una
estrategia digital del gobierno para
apoyar la respuesta sanitaria pero su
uso no es obligatorio excepto para los
viajes aéreos y ha sido poco recurre
entre entre la mayoría de la población
con poco más de 9 millones de descargas
además con la puesta en marcha de las
reapertura la calidad de bogotá lanzó la
aplicación de rastreo epidemiológico
gabo y la web bogotá cuidadora que
genera una fuerte polémica en torno al
manejo de los datos registrados en la
plataforma y la obligatoriedad de su uso
el registro funciona como una encuesta
en línea donde el usuario debe responder
15 preguntas sobre su identificación
teléfono dirección o motivo por el que
se moviliza por lo que muchos ciudadanos
temieron que la encuesta de movilidad
pudiera ser una violación para su
privacidad lo que llevó al distrito
habilitarla como una herramienta de uso
voluntario y no como un certificado de
circulación
[Música]